[Música]
el primer proceso por crímenes de guerra
se realizará en ucrania contra un
soldado ruso según anunció la fiscalía
ucraniana esto mientras quien negocia
con moscú para intercambiar militares de
la planta de as hostal en mariupol por
prisioneros rusos y los ucranianos
retoman terreno en la región de jarquín
tenemos reporte desde una de las aldeas
recuperadas
fracaso en el senado estadounidense un
proyecto de ley para convertir el
derecho al aborto en norma federal los
republicanos lograron un sólido bloque y
hundieron la propuesta ahora la decisión
queda únicamente en manos de la corte
suprema que podría derogar la sentencia
roe versus wait tenemos reportes desde
washington
y en cisjordanía mart mataron a la
periodista irina google una palestino
estadounidense que trabajaba para el
medio al yazira colegas que estaban con
ella sostienen que los militares
israelíes le dispararon mientras que
israel lo niega y propone hacer parte de
la investigación
bienvenidos a france 24 estas son las
noticias más recientes mi nombre es
maría clara calle y empezamos hablando
de ucrania porque allí se realizará el
primer juicio por crímenes de guerra
desde que rusia invadió al país la
principal fiscal ucraniana irina
benedicto va detalló que su oficina
acusó a un sargento por supuestamente
haberle disparado a un civil de 62 años
en una aldea del noreste de ucrania la
funcionaria señaló que el soldado ruso
podría recibir hasta 15 años de cárcel y
añadió que están investigando más de
10.700 presuntos crímenes de guerra
cometidos por rusia el caso se conoce
cuando kiev reveló que están negociando
con moscú para intercambiar militares
ucranianos que están heridos en la
planta de as of talent mariupol por
prisioneros de guerra rusos
las fuerzas armadas ucranianas que están
en heart que sostienen que recuperaron
el control de cuatro aldeas en el norte
y en el noreste de la región una de las
zonas ya recuperadas es el pueblo de
malaya arrojan muestras enviadas irene
sabio y leticia álvarez fueron hasta
allí y esto fue lo que encontraron
estamos en malaya arrojan por dos meses
las tropas rusas ocuparon y atacaron
este pueblo del sur de jarquín en su
asedio a esta importante ciudad la
población local incluso vio los
barracones donde se resguardaban hasta
que el ejército ucraniano retomó el
control de la aldea
la talla pasó semanas en este sótano
mientras las tropas rusas se encontraban
en el pueblo
y de monitor si salíamos a buscar ayuda
humanitaria corríamos el riesgo de que
nos matarán podía ver a los
francotiradores desde la entrada de la
puerta de mi casa tres hombres fueron
asesinados así un hombre caminaba con su
hijo de cuatro años y también lo mataron
helicópteros abatidos hospitales
acribillados automóviles incendiados es
el paisaje de esta aldea los restos de
los combates se ven en todas partes no
queda prácticamente nadie en este pueblo
sólo las personas que resistieron a la
ocupación rusa y la artillería sigue
retumbando en roban otra aldea cercana
badín poljak tiembla al hablar del
desamparo que sintió
[Música]
no entiendo aquí no hay objetivos
militares solo muchas casas en las que
viven personas no entiendo nuestra gente
vivía en paz de u2 de valentina es otra
superviviente nos muestra el salón de su
casa no queda nada intacto
todavía estamos en shock y tenemos miedo
cuando oímos un ruido nos escondemos
enseguida captan la guerra aún está
cerca de estas aldeas el ejército
ucraniano y ruso batallan por pocos
metros de tierra en un conflicto de
desgaste de final incierto
en otras noticias el senado de eeuu
hundió el proyecto con el que se buscaba
proteger el derecho al aborto
convirtiéndolo en una norma federal la
llamada ley de protección de la salud de
la mujer sólo contó con 49 de los 60
votos que necesitaba para su aprobación
y es que todos los 50 republicanos se
opusieron y a ellos se unió el senador
demócrata joe manchin la votación fue
ante los temores de que la corte su
prueba pueda revocar la sentencia roe
versus wade que garantiza la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
desde 1973 en todo el país previamente
nuestro corresponsal en washington
cristóbal vázquez nos explicó porque los
demócratas siguieron adelante con este
proyecto aún sabiendo que no contaban
con los votos necesarios
si varios demócratas afirmaron que
aunque sabían que este resultado iba a
ser negativo avanzaron con esta votación
para hacer un llamado a la acción un
llamado a la acción a sus votantes para
hasta que en noviembre en las elecciones
legislativas salgan a votar por los
candidatos que pues se sumaron a esta
iniciativa de proteger el aborto se
sabía ya que eran 50 demócratas y 50
republicanos dividido el senado así va a
ser muy difícil lograr estos 60 votos
sin embargo los demócratas insistieron
en que querían hacer ver a los
republicanos como extremistas y no y que
no les preocupaba el tema de la
protección a la salud de las mujeres sin
embargo pues muchos analistas acá en
eeuu dicen que los demócratas han tenido
ya varias oportunidades en el pasado
para avanzar este tipo de legislaciones
que protejan el aborto y protejan a la
mujer pero hasta ahora después de esta
información que se filtró de la corte
suprema de justicia que en eeuu hacen
algo dicen él ya es demasiado tarde para
que los demócratas puedan lograr algo
frente al aborto después de todo el
trabajo que vienen haciendo los
republicanos
la suprema corte de justicia de méxico
emitió una sentencia de la que permite
portar más de 5 gramos de marihuana tres
de los cinco magistrados votaron para
declarar inconstitucional una norma que
permitía que el ministerio público
penalizar a el porte de esa cantidad de
cannabis y explicaronque perseguir a los
consumidores es un ataque a la persona
en medio de la decisión decenas de
activistas defensores del uso personal
de la marihuana se manifestaron frente a
la suprema corte ellos sumaron cannabis
llevaron macetas con la planta y
portaron carteles para informar a la
población sobre el consumo responsable
pasamos a medio oriente la periodista
irina buback el corresponsal palestina
estadounidense del medio al yazira fue
asesinada en cisjordania los hechos
ocurrieron mientras informado en la
ciudad de jenín y vestía un chaleco que
claramente decía prensa varios
reporteros que estaban en el lugar
afirman que los militares israelíes le
dispararon pero israel lo niega y dice
que es pronto para saber de dónde vino
el fuego además propone una
investigación gabriel coll quien nos
cuenta
el asesinato de shireen agua que le dejó
al mundo árabe conmocionado en ramala
miles de personas participaron en la
procesión del cuerpo de la periodista
allí manifestaron su tristeza e
indignación por el crimen hay un agua
que le eche en su analista irina bucle
era una periodista muy buena es conocida
en todo el mundo árabe por lo que estoy
muy triste porque es una pérdida para
todos los periodistas árabes palestinos
americanos para todo el mundo apple está
yendo américa a telemundo alianza moody
otro periodista presente durante el
ataque y que resultó herido narró desde
el hospital cómo fueron los hechos en
los que la comunicadora perdió la vida
que la ocupación es asesina y criminal
nos dispararon sin razón alguna nosotros
un grupo de periodistas estábamos allí
con nuestro uniforme de prensa completo
además de los cascos con la palabra
presse escrita en letras grandes y ricas
de la lama con luz en doha los
trabajadores de algeciras rindieron
homenaje al trabajo de la periodista y
destacaron la importancia de seguir
informando desde cisjordania una voz
tenemos otros periodistas valientes que
seguirán cubriendo lo que pasa en el
terreno se que giren estaría encantada
de que sigan trabajando esto no les
parará no dejará de dar voz a los que no
tienen decir dan varios periodistas
también se reunieron en túnez en frente
de la serie del sindicato nacional de
periodistas
sabemos bien que la martín chirino era
una periodista normal sino que
denunciaba los crímenes sionistas y
todas sus prácticas racistas los
asesinatos la devolución la colonización
y los encarcelamientos siren era también
una militante que defendía la causa de
su patria el asesinato fue denunciado
como un ataque de los soldados israelíes
dirigido hacia la periodista pero israel
espera pruebas de una investigación para
pronunciarse
se vendió el diamante blanco jamás
subastado y su precio fue de 21 8
millones de dólares este pesa 228 31
quilates y es tan grande que se le
conoce como de rock o la roca en español
esta piedra preciosa fue extraída y
pulida en sudáfrica hace más de dos
décadas la subasta se realizó este
miércoles en ginebra suiza y fue
liderada por la casa christie's su
precio inicial era de 14,1 millones de
dólares pero pronto en la subasta se
superaron los 20 millones
hasta aquí las noticias los invitamos a
que sigan conectados con france24
[Música]